[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد تعرض شيخ الازهر في مصر
احمد الطيب لهجوم عنيف على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي بسبب الدعوه لتهنئه المسيحيين
باعياد الميلاد وكان قد تقدم الدكتور احمد
الطيب بالتهنئه الى بابا الفاتيكان فرنسيس
والبابا تواضروس الثاني بابا الاسكندريه
البطريار كالكرازه المرقسيه ورئيس ساقفه
كانتربي والاخوه المسيحيين في الشرق
والغرب باعياد الميلاد كما كتب شيخ الازهر
في تغريده نشرت على حسابه على تويتر
باللغه العربيه والانجليزيه دعواته بان
يعلو صوت الاخوه والسلام واسود الامان
والاستقرار في كل مكان
نقش الموضوع من رام الله مع محمود الهباش
قاضي قضاه فلسطين ومستشار الرئيس
الفلسطيني للشؤون الدينيه ومن القاهره
الشيخ عبد العزيز النجار وكيل وزاره سابق
بالازهر مرحبا بكما ضيفيه
الكريمين فضيله الشيخ عبد العزيز في
القاهره ابدا معك هل تهنئه المسيحيين حرام
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم
تحيه لحضرتك وتحيه
لضيفك الكريم الذي يعني نحبه في الازهر
وفي مصر ونعشقه فهو دائما نلتقي به في كل
المؤتمرات الاسلاميه بالنسبه للتهنئه
للمسيحيين في هذا ليس بحرام بل هو واجب
لان بيننا وبينهم اخوه وهي الاخوه
الانسانيه والاخوه في الوطن ولا يمكن ابدا
ان الله عز وجل يقول لا ينهاكم الله عن
الذين لم يقاتلوكم في الدين ولم يخرجوكم
من دياركم انت برهم وتقسطه اليهم ان الله
يحب المقسطين ثم همم نقول ان اننا لا
نهنئهم كيف ان الله عز وجل شرع لنا ان
طعامهم حل لنا وطعامنا حل لهم ناكل ونشرب
ونتزوج اا من نسائهم ان شئنا فهم اهله
كتاب ثم بعد ذلك نجد من عقل له ولا لب له
يقول ان التهنئه حرام يعني نتعامل
366 يوم مع بعض في كل شيء نحن شركاء في
الوطن في العمل في المواصلات في كل شيء في
الدفاع عن الوطن ثم بعد ذلك نقول عندما
ياتي عيدا لهم عندما ياتي عيد لهم نقول ان
هذا حرام هذا ابدا ليس من دين الاسلام
وليس من تعاليم الاسلام وليس من مقاصد
الشريعه الاسلام هم يستاندون الى قول ابن
القيم ولا يفهمون ما قاله ابن القيم اصلا
يعني
فهؤلاء الذين
القيم في هذا الصدد ولماذا يعني لانه اريد
ان افهم من اين جاء مصدر هذا التفكير
فضيله الشيخ لو سمحت
ليس هناك نص شرعي
حديث او ايه قرانيه او قول صحابي ولكن
يقول ابن القيم واما التهنئه بشعائر الكفر
المختصه به فحرام بالاتفاق مثل ان يهنيهم
باعيادهم وهكذا فابن القيم عندما يتحدث هو
لا يتحدث عن اهل همم الكتاب لم يتحدث عن
اليهود ولم يتحدث عن النصارى بل ابن القيم
في فتوه يتحدث عن اهل الكفر ونحن ايضا
الكفار همم الذين همم يعني لا يؤمنون
بالله عز وجل لهم من اهل الكتاب لا هم من
اليهود ولا هم من النصارى هؤلاء اصلا نحن
لا نهنئكم باعيادهم وانما اهله الكتاب كما
قال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم عندما جاء
في في في عاشوراء
ما هذا اليوم قال في المدينه قالوا نحن
يوم نصوم لان الله نجى فيه الله موسى من
الغرق قد نحن اولى بموسى منهم وصمه النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم فيقول في حديث اخر همم
انا اول انا اولى انا اولى انا اولى بعيسى
همم مريم النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول
انا اولى بعيسى ابن مريم ويقول ليس بيني
وبينه نبي ثم يبين النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم ان الانبياء همم ابناءه او اولاد
علالات امهاتهم شتى ودينهم يعني عندنا في
الفقه الاسلامي ال- الاخوه اللي هم من اب
وامهاتهم شطه يقال ابناء همم
طيب همم ضيفي من رام الله فضيله الشيخ
محمود الهباش كذلك اهلا بك معنا مره اخرى
ما رايك في هذا الجدل لانه حقيقه يعني
هناك يعني همم
تفضل به فضيله الشيخ من القاهره مهم ويعني
يؤكد على انه همم يعني همم مساله التهنئه
بالاعياد يعني هي مساله انسانيه بعثتها
ليست لها علاقه
بالدين كما يفعل الاخوه المسيحيون مع
المسلمين في شهر رمضان همم المسلمون كذلك
يهنئهم باعياد الميلاد كذلك فلماذا يعني
نجد هذه الاصوات التي تقيم الدنيا ولا
تقعدها عندما يكون الامر متعلق بتهنئه في
عيد يعني مع همم يعني عنصر موجود معنا في
حياتنا في مجتمعتنا من اين جاء هذا
التفكير وكيف يمكن همم يعني النظر الى الى
هذه الاصوات
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله تحياتي لك وتحياتي
لضيفك الدكتور النجار من القاهره ومن
خلاله كل التحيه للازهر الشريف
وليمامه وجمهوريه مصر العربيه ولكل امتنا
العربيه والاسلاميه ثانيا
اسمح لي ان نتقدم بخالص التهنئه
للمسلمين والمسيحيين على حد سواء
بميلاد السيد المسيح عليه السلام الذي هو
مناسبه لنا جميعا
للمسلم والمسيحي
وللانسان بشكل عام السيد المسيح ايه من
ايات الله
استذكار يوم مولده بغض النظر عن الاختلاف
في تحديد اليوم بشكل دقيق لكن ال
الاستذكار يوم المولد والاحتفال بيوم
ميلاد المسيح عليه السلام كما الاحتفاء
والاحتفال بمولد سيدنا المصطفى محمد صلى
الله عليه وسلم هذه ايام من ايام الله
والله عز وجل يقول وذكرهم بايام الله
المسيح ايه من ايات الله واستذكار مولده
واستذكار لقدره الله تبارك وتعالى
نبعث الجدل مع الاسف الشديد حول هذه
المساله
واشباهها من المسائل المماثله مبعثه الجهل
الجهل المطبق لدى البعض الذين لا يقراون
واذا قراوا لا يفهمون واذا تكلموا لا
يعرفون ماذا يقول
ديننا دين كامل وهذه المساله
كما تفضلت يعني مساله انسانيه ولكنها ايضا
مثل دينيه لان ديننا وقواعد ديننا تامرنا
بالاحسان الى الناس ماذا يمكن ان نقول في
قول الله تبارك وتعالى
وقولوا للناس حسنا ما قال قولوا للمؤمنين
قال قولوا للناس لكل الناس المسلم وغير
المسلم لا ينهاكم الله عن الذين لم
يقاتلوكم في الدين ولم يخرجوكم من دياركم
ان تبروهم وتقسطوا اليهم
كيف نبرهم ونقسط اليهم اذا لم نكن نشاركهم
في افراحهم واتراعهم اذا لم نكن نتعاطى
معهم كبشر كجيران كشركاء في الوطن كشركاء
في الانسانيه وما اجمل ما قال سيدنا
الامام علي رضي الله عنه الناس صنفان اما
اخ لك في الدين او نظير لك في الخلق
فكيف يمكن ان
نسلك مع هؤلاء الناس الا مثل هذا السلوك
السوي القائم على قواعد ديننا التي تامر
بالاحسان الى الناس وبالخلق السويه مع
الجميع
الحقيقه فضيله الشيخ في القاهره الاستاذ
محمود الهباش يعني اشار الى نقطه مهمه جدا
كذلك يعني حتى في مساله يعني همم الاحتفال
بمولد النبي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم يعني
هناك ايضا هناك من يحرم الاحتفال بذلك فما
بالك بتهنئه
المسيحيين كذلك في اعياد الميلاد همم يعني
هذا التفكير همم كيف يمكن تقويمه
ويعني بتبيان الصوره الحقيقيه بانه يا اخي
لا يجب التوقف عند هذه الامور والذهاب
يعني برساله التسامح وقبول الاخر وهمم
يعني
الذهاب بهذا الاتجاه الانساني وعدم التوقف
عند هذه الامور خاصه وانه ليس لديها دليل
شرعي كما تفضلت حتى دينيه يعني لا في
الحديث ولا في القران هنا كما يدعم هذا
التوجه
شوف حضرتك
انا اؤيد ما قاله اخي وفضيله الشيخ محمود
الهباش ان هذا ينبئ عن جهل هؤلاء لان
دائما العالم عنده كثير من الرخص وعنده
سعه في الفهم ويستطيع ان يفهم النصوص وان
يبين الاحداث لكن هؤلاء لا يفقهون ولا
يعقلون عندما نتحدث عن ميلاد النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم او عن ميلاد
المسيح عليه السلام ما الذي يضرها هؤلاء
انني احتفلوا
بسيدنا عيسى وانا احب سيدنا عيسى وانا
احتفل بسيدنا محمد وانا احب سيدنا محمد
وشرط في امامي ان اؤمن بجميع الانبياء امن
الرسول بما انزل اليه من ربه والم كله
الامانه بالله وملائكته وكتبه ورسل لا
نفرق بين احد من رسله فنحن لا نفرق بين
سيدنا عيسى وسيدنا موسى وسيدنا محمد وجميع
الرسل فكما اننا نحتفل بميلاد سيدنا محمد
نحتفل باولاد سيدنا عيسى ثم ما الذي يضرها
همم
اقول لاخي في الوطن واخي في الانسانيه
واهنئه
بالعياده واشاركه احزاني نعم هل معنى ذلك
انني سيرته على ملته ودينه وهل هو عندما
يهنئني بعيد او بمناسبه دينيه عندي ساره
مسلمه
طبعا همم
عندما يهنئ همم فضيله الشيخ الازهر الشيخ
احمد الطيب المسيحيين في اعيادهم كذلك هل
برايك هذا يسهم في تغيير النظره بفهم
اكثر ااا للاسلام من ضمن التحدث عن شيخ
الازهر يقوم بهذه الخطوه رغم هذه الاصوات
المنتقده همم يعني عن جهل كما تفضلت اا هل
يغير هذا من هذه الثقافه الموجوده للاسف
اه بالتاكيد طبعا ان فضيله الامام يتحدث
اعذرني فضيله الشيخ السؤال الشيخ محمود
الهباش
الاكبر عندما يتحدث ونحن نتحدث بصوت واحد
عندما يتحدث الامام الاكبر وهو يتحدث عن
علم ويتحدث عن معرفه وعن واعي هذا شيخ
الازهر وليس مجرد طالب علم او طويله بعلم
هنا او هناك او ربما يعني شخص قرا حديثا
او حديثين او كتابا او كتابين ثم جاء يفتي
هذا شيخ الازهر الرجل الذي يتدفق علمه
مؤسسه هي مرجعيه العلوم الشرعيه في العالم
الاسلامي اليوم وبالتالي عندما يتحدث وهو
يتحدث
عن
دعوهنا شكرا
وعلى التسامح حتى حتى
الموضوع جميل جدا ويستهل كثير من الوقت
هنا في بانوراما محمود الهباش قدره فلسطين
شكرا جزيلا لك وفضل الشيخ عبد العزيز
النجار وكيل وزاره سابق في الازهر شكرا
شادي الكرام شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده
الاخبار مستمره